hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to will you press the
button now I was gonna mix things up and
there's a setting in the settings menu
that allows you to see the unapproved
questions and there's like 7,000
approved questions to 350,000 unapproved
questions so I was in my mind I was like
how bad could it be they're they're
probably cool at least some interesting
they're bad oh god they're bad I'll show
you
they're bad they're horrible not only
grammatically but situationally like
this you can watch any anime you want
anytime an HD right when it comes out it
will all be dubbed like old Japanese
well this isn't okay this one's totally
fine this one's 100% fine this is a bad
example I must've just come across a few
uh well okay maybe it's okay I I got
into there was some heavily racist stuff
and I got like a string of it so I guess
I can try this we'll see how it goes and
then I'll just cut out the bad ones okay
all right cool you become the greatest
sportsman alive but no one will ever
cheer for you in your events so you can
score the greatest goals in soccer and
the whole stadium will just be dead
silent or will they boo you because
there's a big difference but I guess
rolling around and all the money you'd
get from being the greatest sportsman
would be good enough for not having
people cheer for you okay I'll press it
why not you can become invisible at any
time but you have to be naked to do so
now see this doesn't seem so bad because
I'm naked like 90% of my day anyway so
what does it matter if I just get naked
in my house go out unless it's like some
condition where you have to hold your
breath but maybe that's not at or maybe
I just walk around with a trench coat at
all times and just flash people in the
nude and then run around town it's got
weird nevermind I'll press it screw it I
like I like being naked you get
everything you want for free but you
lose a family member for everything you
get now this is bad
what if I want a Chipotle burrito and my
brother has to die that seems like a bad
trade-off you gotta let go for something
big like I won
the moon then what does that mean that
you're on the moon I guess you can can
you encapsulate the entirety of the
earth ownership of it completely or do
you have to get things individually like
on a small level cuz that doesn't seem
very good
I will not maybe I don't know so no
chase no Saddam eh but Josh I don't know
why that one's really funny to me I
don't know what it means but it's the
idea whatever the hell the first one is
bite Jo Jo I'll press it whatever the
hell that means tell me what I did and
see you can heal and take away pain from
anybody else not from you but you have
to feel all the pain when you take it
away okay that seems like an interesting
power considering that you can heal them
but does that mean that you bear the
pain permanently or just bear the pain
temporarily because that's a big thing
if you just run around healing people
but the more people you heal the more
incredible this pain becomes that's like
a horrifying dilemma you can heal people
like incredible wounds can be healed
instantly but you have to bear that pain
for the rest of your life and you reach
a critical moment where you've taken
away so much pain that suddenly you
can't take it anymore and you just die
from the pie of no idea that would be
that would be such a weird sacrifice
I'll do it you have the ability to fly
but you can no longer walk or swim well
that seems okay I hope leases go
everywhere hovering a little bit off the
ground down at the grocery store pushing
my cart of goodies offering a few inches
off the ground I don't see a trade-off
depends on how fast I can fly God if I
can only fly it a walking speed would be
terrible
but I think I'd be okay I'll I'll take
that that sounds pretty good you are
invincible but you must sacrifice one
person every day holy crap that's a lot
of commitment to have do they have to
submit themselves to me or do I have a
cult that's bringing them in am I the
leader of some dark group
oh man is it the sacrifice that actually
makes me invincible I don't know when I
don't sacrifice um one one day and then
get the next am i okay I don't know yeah
sure why not I blew up all of Detroit I
always have to remember that I put that
in perspective I blew up Detroit for a
piece of cake I think I'm okay you have
a VIP past every concert movie and event
free entrance no line but after it after
you use it each time you can't have sex
for a month well how is that any
different from my normal life I'll press
it in to see dude you can breathe
underwater but you can never get dry
again wow that has so many ulterior
meanings write in the comments the
different ways that could be interpreted
onus points for the dirtier it is now I
just know everyone's gonna be confused
if they look at the comments before the
video is actually like they've gone
through the video they're gonna be very
confused why everyone's writing such
dirty things
yeah I'll press it fine okay just oh
I'll just be moist man walking through
the world just slightly moist you can go
into any fictional world you want movie
show book etc but your favorite
character hates you and there's no way
of changing it well you know what [ __ ]
that guy [ __ ] you Harry Potter I'm gonna
hang out with Ron Weasley oh god but
what oh that that changes things what if
when you go in there your favorite
character hates you so then you start to
like another character and then you'll
know when they become your favorite
character because suddenly they'll hate
you and you have to shift back and forth
I guess you'd meet so many people I'll
press it screw it why not
you're very wealthy but you can only use
the money on others and never yourself
unless it's steak and water that is an
odd exclusion there why just steak and
why just water waters kind of free in
most parts of the world I mean I guess I
wouldn't be too upset about that I can
make sure that other people were
well-off sure yeah why not you know what
I like steak you can make any person
fall in love with you but that person
will die in five years okay now here's
the
what if you make all of the horrible
horrible people of the world fall in
love with you and then they'll die cuz
you don't have to be in love with them
but if you make like all of the the
worst people of the world like all the
horrible dictators and all the
terrorists and all that stuff you know
then fall in love with you and then you
know they'll be happy and in love and
the [ __ ] years later they just die maybe
that'd be a weird superpower I'll take
it you become the most famous rich and
powerful person on the planet but you
must marry the person you hate most on
this planet regardless of gender well I
don't really hate anyone and just
because I'm married doesn't mean that I
have to do a whole lot I mean if the
standards of marriage these days is
anything to go by
yes sure okay you know I'm okay
I'll do that yeah you become a master 3d
modeler but they can never be made in
the real world by 3d printer or
otherwise and must not violate copyright
well that seems totally fine because for
most 3d modelers they're working in
games and movies and such and they don't
need to be in the word real-world so I
think that's actually okay I just learn
a really good skill you can read the
opposite sex money but people of the
same sex can hear your thoughts now that
is a fascinating dilemma so it's kind of
like a what women want situation where
he can hear all women thoughts but all
the guys can hear my thoughts loud and
clear and I think that'd be ok because I
don't speak for all guys but I'm pretty
sure we're all thinking pretty much the
same thing I mean not to say everyone's
the same but my thoughts are incredibly
generic and if everyone can hear them
they'd probably just be bored to death
so I don't think that's too bad I got
nothing to hide to my bros it'll be ok
oh god you have a beautiful girlfriend
boyfriend but every time you sleep
together they shart on your face
hi is it intentional can I talk to them
about it is it like a sleepwalking thing
except their sleep sharding and it just
happens to be on my face I mean you'd
think we would discuss this a little bit
but apparently not so I don't know I've
I'd know you know you know what nothing
oh my gos no you can instantly play any
string instrument without having to even
study it but you orgasm with every strum
of a note that's incredible it would be
an amazing power you just start out with
a solo Jam and get the best huh oh never
mind I'll press it I'll bear this burden
everybody I'll take this one for the
team you can eat anything you want
without putting on weight but you have
to take suppositories the size of
peanuts every morning are we talking the
size of just you know a normal peanut I
mean I'm already trying to justify this
because it doesn't seem like too much of
a trade-off unless I was trying to be a
bodybuilder and I'm not saying I'm
trying to be a bodybuilder but if I
wanted to put on muscle weight then this
seems kind of like a problem but it says
I have to take suppositories to make it
not happen so I imagine that if I didn't
take the suppositories I could gain
weight if I wanted to this seems like a
pretty good deal and maybe in the future
of medical silence is actually how it's
gonna be done
no president why not you become famous
and everybody likes you but you must
kill five of your fans of your choice
every day everyone still likes you and
the killing of those five fans does not
affect you at all except maybe mentally
Wow
I don't think the price of fame is worth
killing five of my fans unless they're
all like very happily it's like a
horrifying cult where let's just take
for example you guys if you guys lined
up outside my door in sacrificial robes
like please mark please me no oh god no
I'm not even theorizing this anymore
that's horrible that's a [ __ ]
Oh horrible you will never have to sleep
again but you have to run 10 miles every
morning now that doesn't seem like too
much of a trade-off you gain eight hours
a day and all you have to do is run ten
mile you would get in great shape you
would get in incredible shape and you'd
have so much more time you'd never have
to sleep that's awesome
unless it's not awesome no it's awesome
I'll press that screw that I'll press it
oh this one is strangely pertinent your
friend will be PewDiePie but you will
learn from PewDiePie a lot of being a
youtuber wow it's almost like that
actually happened in my life huh that's
it's a bizarre conundrum oh I guess all
pro ah whoo-hoo-hoo no you gain either
firebending waterbending earthbending or
airbending but everyone hates you I am
NOT an expert on avatar or The Legend of
Korra so this one doesn't quite fall
within my category of nerdism which is a
large category admittedly
but I'll leave this one up to you for
those fans of the shows out there would
you be willing to be able to do one of
these random things I suppose this
random but have everyone suddenly hate
you
probably because you're so cool and able
to do these magical things so I'll leave
that one up to you let me know in the
comments below it'll be right alongside
all the Vickery dirty comments but it'll
be cool nonetheless can't wait to see
your answers thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you
in the next bro for this guy what should
I name them